on the
floor um I mean I don't know I mean
obviously they scored a bunch of points
but that's what they capable of doing I
thought we had some chances um but you
every time we made a run um they was
able to come back and either go like a80
run six0 run whatever the case may be
you know we got it down was close to 10
in that fourth quarter and then boom
boom boom Le kind of went back up but
suppose the record reflects that you've
had some clear positive moments and some
clear negative moments this year right
kind of going back and forth what do you
have to do going into these next two New
York Boston a couple tough games to to
find that uh the positive side of it let
play our game uh try to be better be
better in transition um try not to turn
the ball over for pick sixes you know
those are hard to uh recover from um so
you know obviously we got two really
really damn good teams you know coming
up especially obviously Boston at home
at the end we lost one home game you
know so we just got to be better the
circumstances of second half of a backto
back travel and no ad certainly are
things that do factor into the game um
did you feel like that aside though your
guys kind of togetherness and effort was
where it should have been tonight and
when and in what in your to get effort
in what quarter I'm sorry I didn't hear
you not thought you said oh tonight um
at times at times it wasn't but that's
our
record it is what it is 37 minutes last
night 36 tonight do you think the fans
appreciate what you're doing at 39 years
old and like how hard is it for you to
still play at your level um I don't
really get involved in that or the
thought process that I just try when I'm
healthy enough to go out there and play
I just try to perform at a high level
help my teammates uh do great things on
the floor try to be productive and uh
and when lose a draw be you know
satisfied with the way I approach the
game so um that's all I can ask for
myself what's the best way for you guys
to be connected on defense with ads not
in there it's difficult as that may be
um you know there got to be more
communication throughout the you know
the course of an um uh of a possession
um because you can have a little you
know slippage when ad is out there
because he protects us on that on that
third line of defense but you know when
he's not out there it has to be constant
communication and not on the floor so
when we do have the slippers we least
have guys that's protecting but also ad
does a great job of defensive rebounding
I mean there's times tonight where we
were getting really good stops but we
either couldn't clean glass or the ball
or go off our hands out of bounds they
still have the possession
Soo tonight was not very good yeah that
started with me though was ass from the
free throw line last two games so I got
to be better starts with me Lebron
team's scoring more points this season
than any season since 1970 what do you
why do you think there's so much scoring
going on right now um just uh the way
the game is and the way it's uh better
for the fans and the way the officiates
rest the game is for freedom of movement
it's the same way of why do we see so
many passing yards in
NFL it's the same thing as good as the
the Knicks and the seltic are um
this group you know you guys have had
some big stages this year where you
played well and those are two Arenas
there's always energy there um you know
do you feel like you guys could put it
together and and look a lot um we could
On Any Given Night Beat any team in the
NBA and then On Any Given night we get
our ass kicked by any team in the
NBA that's just a what's our
record 500 under 500 one game under 500
but
2425 that's where we are last question
Brian you guys are C staying on the road
for the next couple games big match up
against Boston big match up against the
Knicks what would your message be to
your teammate and what can you do
yourself you know to get that get pick
back on the winning side of things I
don't have any message for my teammates
just go out and do your
job